welcome to this video round for ya
always need to look that I brought for
coverage of the dash team of memoria
from other by John Schanke as the city
wanna play and II around form we got in
fact three interesting games today but
okay I decided to just pick one for game
of the day and game of the day will be
Kara wanna playing white against the
world champion magnus carlsen playing
black briefly about the two other games
we had two draws in those games kayaking
played wide against nobody are off and
there was some interestingly enough
repetition of the caro-kann advance so
mama dro firm who had lost the day
before against da camera played the same
line again again the caracal again with
the quick see 5k I can't ride them as he
mentioned in the post mortem press
conference try the known woulda idea
that he had prepared but nobody are off
simply found all the right response is
necessary to to even the game so they
had a relatively quick draw in terms of
moves but it was still quite interesting
um I didn't intend that actually to
found the end quite amusing here we look
at this somewhat crazy looking position
white attacking the rook on d6 on the
other hand White's king is also wide
open Black Keys Kings on da did some
would look somewhat random this position
there is only one way to play as black
to to get also lets in to not land into
serious trouble and this is to give away
the rook interestingly enough f takes g4
is by far the strongest move and it
leads to a draw everything else leads to
big trouble and what seems that why does
not have anything better than taking the
rook which after g3 leads to an
immediate made threat and white can
really
not prevent that unless you take sanji
three instances they only move other
moves lead to yeah quick defeat so it
takes check and now we had this
perpetual check with the Queen checking
and therefore a draw was some was a
greet here rather early but sometimes it
happens with those sharp lines the other
game was for a job of playing white
against Nakamura and here like I were up
late at the Slav again he trusts his
defenses there it seems and despite his
loss in round two against Carlin and
it's it seemed that raja baath had a
slightly more comfortable position why
not briefly look at it Chester to get
the general picture this kind of
position we we had you know we see that
it is equal material four pawns four
pawns but why it has somewhat the more
comfortable position there is pressure
here pressure on d5 and he managed to
activate nicely but nakamura played an
excellent defense and at the end it it
was a draw after a very long fight in
the end game so I didn't want to get
into detail here but I'm a very good
good level game ready with a good
defense and a job of putting some some
pressure he seems to be in pretty decent
shape again in this tournament a job
after having lost really a ton of rating
points in the last year okay so um let's
go to the main part of the of this video
caruana cards and yes it is the dreaded
berlin defense to them to the ROI in a
way of yeah let's say
the bane of every one in four player
nowadays how to get anything against
them the Berlin koala has played many
lines against this well they're mostly
two choices of course there is the end
game with castles this is what he played
in the game and they is d3 as well he
has tried both but here he went for
castles and allowed the endgame yeah and
of course no Knight takes e4 and d4 was
played and we come to this check now
famous endgame the so-called Berlin Wall
end game that really was put to the
limelight by chrome Nick in his world
championship match in the year 2000
where Kasparov really a banked his head
against this wall and never really got
anywhere I mean he me got some good
positions but he could win a game which
basically was the decider in the match
as chrome Nick back then 12 games with
white and simply didn't lose anything
with her with black which was unheard of
in a match against Kasparov okay I'm
here for quite a number of yes the main
move has been Knight to c3 after that
black cam has a big choice Bishop d7
Darius Bishop e7 king e8 h 6 and so on
but in recent times the move h3 has
gained some popularity one reason for
this is that it is directed against a
particular set up that black sometimes
chooses this is the set up with Bishop
to d7 after Knight c3 Bishop d7 as one
move that is considerably popular black
intends to play quick King c8 Bishop e7
rook d8 something like that blacks only
problem in this position end but it is a
serious problem is of course that he
lost castling rights and this is not bad
for the king rainy but bad for the rooks
it's very tough to connect trucks IAM
it's almost yeah in dublin if black
manages to connect the rooks or get both
books into play sometimes the rooks get
into player from the initial squares
it's not like they need to get to e8 or
d8 necessarily sometimes there are
things happening like pawn to h4 and
look to h5 for example and but ok well
Bishop d7 is one way to prepare the
brook connection later and this h3 move
is pointed again that because after this
white has an interesting addition an
option you can try to gain space now
immediately on the King side g49 to is
795 this is the idea of the early h3
move after Bishop we ate for example
what can even play a quick f4 which is
very sharp and at least a way to ya to
do to look for something as wide I mean
it's a really am very very difficult to
get anything against this opening so I
think white players are glad that there
is this additional option at least
against one particular setup however
after h3 black has many other ways he
can play there is king he ate there is
h5 ya taleb played h6 check look do you
wanna check king here yeah note that if
black goes Bishop d7 now it runs into a
more than serious problem white wins
instantly here so you must go to aid
it's not the end of the world but it's
um somewhat again a bit of a limitation
of blogs options now this h6 moves by
the way is designed to prepare the
bishop development to v6
black wants to avoid the bishop getting
attacked a media with immediately with
noisy five so age takes us the
preparation for that in an earlier round
and we had posit korea koala crow
kayaking hiking plain black I'm not not
one hundred percent sure i think it was
um kayaking is black normally plays with
h5 and judging from promise games i
think this is also very interesting as
head up I don't know the Berlin in much
detail I must admit I am it's only what
I am gathered from from time to time
looking at top level games i have played
this line sometimes in the in the in the
past but i stopped a stop playing the
berlin in favor of the the main line
simply with a six and someone like that
she Goren the briar simply because i
wanted to have somewhat yeah more more
complicated battle in a way I didn't
want to trade down so quickly as black
so my experience is really limited okay
Kingy 893 and Bishop d7 hero as
mentioned Bishop e6 was the initial idea
but this is not not a bad news one
problem of this by the way could be that
g4 97-94 could be could be a bit
annoying him yeah I guess that's the
reason for Bishop d7 Bishop d7 I mean
the main idea of this is any way to get
in quickly rook the eighth and probably
Bishop Bishop move again to trade one
pair of rooks which would is also
helpful to black black has somewhat less
space so it does not mind to trade them
some some pieces especially the rooks as
this is the main problem of his position
the rooks are in the corner is not doing
much okay Bishop f4 developing
the bishop does not really have any any
better Square and one point about the
bishop being on f4 is always this idea
to play an e5 to e6 at the right moment
and open up the position it looks a bit
or it sounds a bit bit strange that
white would actually open would like to
open the position as Black has got the
bishop Pam but the the problem that
black has is not let's say the
opportunities that white hair Sen this
position are mostly connected with the
concrete measures using the somewhat or
slightly disturbed coordination and
blacks Kemp so those direct approaches
are very interesting of course it really
must net something concrete those kind
of technical director ideas but it's not
uncommon this set up our MOOC t8 no 94
was played at least according to my
database this is a novelty looks
perfectly normal to smooth but it seems
to be new and in earlier game kawana
poonam I off now while I have played
actually II six aha so Bishop e6 Bishop
c7 this was this was played and after
the capture here and did the should be
seven the game later was some was drawn
yeah the idea he as as mentioned it it's
very concrete and to get this yeah using
the just by playing with the moves that
actually gain gain time attacking
attacking the bishop that probably does
not want to be captured Bishop back and
now rookie one was played so threatening
here well upon my of at the end term
equalized this was the draw after
50 moves on this seems to be the
intended improvement 94 and he look at
the clock times all this was played
rather quickly yeah and now what is some
blacks set up here he played Bishop e7
called it after about 15 minutes and
this intense to trade the nights with
night to h4 in general from what i
remember when i studied the the berlin a
bit and this is not about concrete lines
but about structures it was usually
quite beneficial for black to to get the
night traded um not because well let's
phrase it differently um the night on f5
can be a bit of a tricky piece as it
often gets kicked by g4 and it's
normally better to have it exchanged
than to sort of drop it back reroute it
and so on so after this volcarona played
g4 and we have the straight now um after
that i don't know it feels like black
should be perfectly okay here with this
trade being accomplished kingi to this
is some quite quite a logical
continuation it protects the eaves h3
paul is one thing and it prepares
further advance of the king in the end
game so quite a normal-looking move
Bishop to e6 okay like once the trade a
pair of rooks seems fairly logical f3
new lending some support to the night
this was also an idea and now b6 was
played covering the c5 square can be
three yeah it's difficult for why to not
play this at some point and one idea is
to have this this block here
to answer c5 with c4 yeah and now we get
get this position um this is in fact
interesting and worth explaining was a
bit too quick here Bishop g3 should like
take now on g3 are not in fact he didn't
take he retreated to e7 um and this is
very very instructive black shouldn't
absolutely not trade it's um there is a
general reason of course you want to
keep your your bishop pal but there is
also another another very concrete
reason if you just look at this this
structure the King on g3 is very well
placed it helps really with the white um
advance on the kingside f4 f5 King f4
even this move will come very very quick
here and black is in huge trouble I have
fun just for verification issues I have
stockfish Enda in the background it's
not the super strongest engine but it
gives only 0.6 for white ear which seems
i don't know i think what is much much
much better ok so allah black shouldn't
really trade you really shouldn't so we
treated to e7 no white took on on d7
young it counts recaptured with the
bishop if you take with the king it can
easily happen that after after F for you
run into the risk of ya gettin getting
squashed by the pawns you're not sure
you want to play g 6 cm so he sort of it
took on this happen with the bishop to
to be better prepared for the f word
once if white now plays f4 there is this
move age 5
yet after f5 and capturing you have
Bishop to c6 and with that you could
really activate your bishop nicely so I
think this was a good good decision to
take with the bishop yeah 93 now and
this is a really strong with the night
only form it looked nice but it didn't
do so much it wasn't attacking anything
and the knight on d5 on the other hand
is doing something it looks at e 7 it
looks at c7 and they put some pressure
on the structure this this pawn
structure here so I think this is a good
regrouping yeah I note that black in
this position and does not want to play
c76 too pretty to prevent 95 as this
really weakens the structure in the
center and on the queenside especially
the 26 square white will probably just
returned and at some point put the night
on d6 I mean really at some point not at
any point like when black can take it
and get to an opposite colored bishops
and game there need to be it needs to be
prepared decently he played a king to
the eighth which seems fine you know 95
maybe he had the idea after Luke do you
want to play King c8 something like that
95 Bishop d8 and then sort of go for a
CH 54 rook e8 at the right moment using
the rook all right this whole position
it it feels a bit uncomfortable for
black just a bit I mean from what I have
seen in many games and in the Berlin
Wall I'm very often black has no
problems whatsoever it's just like just
yeah and no pressure even on black and
here there is there is a bit of pressure
it does not does not feel very
comfortable on rock t 1 was not played
come on a plate 95 first and this at
least of course prevents King to see
eight so black needs to D needs to do
something else he played rookie at 1st
to prepare that and now Luke d1 was
played yeah and in this position look at
the clock time scales had 37 minutes
left while we know that this time see on
is ser just just very the abbot wake
yeah they're not completely precise but
i can tell you and this i watched this
life yeah only spend a couple of seconds
on the move king to see eight and if you
want to look at this position and try to
figure out what the quran i did did you
know I you can stop the video if you
like to give you to give yourself a bit
more time White has a very strong move
now and I'm pretty confident that you
are able to find it alright so I hope
you found the move kawana took on the c7
it took like two minutes on that simply
because probably needed to check if this
is a dream or something because what
cars had just blundered this porn
there's really no other explanation for
that why he would give up this this porn
yeah after night take c7 I mean why does
just just winning now so what was Kings
yet just the blunder probably it was I
mean one thing is it's pretty clear that
black needs to do something concrete now
because this is a through jet and King
c8 is just completely ignoring the
threat um so what should like do we
probably must play c6 here which is not
ideal that
much is clear I mean it's not to move
that you absolutely love to play right
now has two options basically um yeah I
mean okay one option is clearly the best
better one but even 97 just showing it
leads to a very nice position for white
because after rook takes f four white is
just much much better coordinated here
the King can easily help and you bet you
have a pawn based on the King side for
again three while the other majority is
not doing so much this is quite nice for
white but I think even stronger would be
just to retreat to e3 and then push the
pawns there's also at the right moment
maybe night at five let will probably
prevent that but this is just not
looking very nice I mean black is
suffering a bit yet he still should have
to have decent chances to hold but white
has has something here and what I cannot
really tell how this how this happened
um it's very tricky to to figure out I
mean maybe some some moves here in this
area can be improved upon this is this
is quite possible so i'm not i'm not one
hundred percent sure where calzon been
wrong because he was some in slight
discomfort anyway and well in this
position where it already was a bit
tricky he blundered with king CA dia um
and I think it really was it was a
blunder this was played very quickly
yeah well 97 was played and now I'm just
to show it briefly wear black cannot
ever take half this is just a disaster
what gets on the 7th and and wins the
house like this check yeah this is even
a maid checkmate so black needs to go
somewhere else I don't know yeah here
probably check yeah and like like will
lose everything here yeah cannot take so
you need to move the rook no doubt about
that and what come on i just dropped
back to d5 and night b5 also was was a
good-looking move but you can really
easily um make life hard hard for
yourself just check this it looks very
good at first sight if you look at it
more closely you see that now black is
quick enough to get the king to d5 and
I'm not 100% sure that this is a totally
easy win probably white should win here
as well but no this is an act of peas on
d5 and it's not so clear how exactly do
you get your your passer on the Kings
side what you played is just stronger
drop back to d5 and now route yet it's
just like you just snatched this pawn
and then retweet it and this means that
the knight on d5 is pretty much a
monster it can never be a kicked away
with the Seaport anymore because it's
had been taken and why it can easily in
proof of his position behind the night
the night ties down legs hold position
and white is improving this is by the
way it was a very nice maneuver I think
the bishop 1g3 had his function and
pressurizing the Queen side especially
c7 yeah and dwell who mission
accomplished c7 has fallen due to this
tactic so when the bishop is not doing
much anymore so he reroute sit to see
three where there is something on g7 to
look at and it still has a very nice
roll on c3 to to cover the importantly
five-speed porn just very nice maneuver
yeah now very slowly karana improved his
position yeah this b5 move looks a bit
like weakening yourself as black but you
want some activity for the bishop so
it's very understandable what what cards
did also note the clock times he played
almost instantly now which if you are
really in a bad shape can be a good
recipe just to try to put the the other
side under some pressure on the clock
that he needs to move all the time that
yes not any time to think while you
spend time the other interesting
strategy by the way if you are really in
bad shape is to let your clock run down
to almost nothing and get yourself into
big-time trouble this is a fairly fairly
wacky idea but it sometimes is a good
idea because it irritates the hell out
of the other side sometimes that you are
basically disability going into time
travel it can be an idiot if you are so
so so much worse then it can be the sort
of the last effort that you can try okay
let's see what happens rook t2 strong
move again covering the a pawn it was it
was much worse to play a move like that
Bishop comes back to the seven
maybe gets to the b3 porn maybe a five
is also looking very good for wider the
rook is just not well placed yeah but
rock d 2 is just a good move covering
from the side keeping the active
position on the D file and well what
white must do is he needs to hold the
fault on the queenside make sure that
there is no breakthrough I anything
happening and then slowly push the King
side and central majority home and
basically this is what what happened
Jack know why it has a very nice night
position on d6 he got the night there
and the pawn is pushed and all the way
to have six note that the capture here
after Bishop h4 it's not really
necessary I mean you have all the time
in the world and you shouldn't really
try to calculate all this yet it's just
it just not necessary to snatch so
quickly f6 is just a strong move it
prevents any bishop ideas by blocking it
and does the f7 porn is still very weak
so you can take it at a later stage
Bishop to b6 and here this is a very
very good a very interesting spot again
just a very good practical thing move
for Tia this is move 40 the last move to
to make before the time control is
happening koala hat about one and a half
minute left and the question is do you
take on f7 or not taking on f7 so if you
look at this and you had only have
little time you will see that see for
the reply and one alarm bells go off
there is a mate threat on g1 so
something like that checkmate
so good so you will probably see that
okay I need to do something against the
mate and what can I do against the mate
hmm not quite sure what to do against it
so you have 1 minute 30 seconds you
shouldn't take the pawn it's just like
that it's not a good practical thing to
do he just played 94 back this kills
this bishop this Bishop is now looking
at this own pawn on c5 and why it has
all the time in the world now after move
40 he gets the additional I think it's
an hour here in this indiscernible so
all the time to figure out things now
rookie 896 back and now while you're
black does not really want to play a
passive move like okay wait um just not
doing any good besides white can take
here but this is an additional problem
those points were when the day yeah
Carlton was playing with g8 and now this
is basically the same position that we
had before just with ya two moves edit
and now karana had the time to figure
out that you can take he just took his
time why not it took them c4 was played
as mentioned and now aged fraud this is
the key move that needed to be
calculated white now has this additional
idea getting the night back and then
pushing the pawns and it turns out that
he had to assess this correctly Black
has no serious counter chances if black
gives the check you go to h3 and there
is simply nothing bad happening to the
king but this is not so easy to figure
out with one minute on the clock so he
didn't go for that but he took the 20 25
minutes to make sure that there is
nothing happening and in fact there is
nothing happening here cars have tried
something else he went for this this
rookie formals e6
and Bishop e3 yeah he could have taken
yet but check after a couple of checks
the the fun is all over for black and
wall this is coming nothing to do really
this is and then 95 f7 the pawns just
promote yeah Bishop e3 was played check
check check and now Bishop g3 blocking
the check on g2 and now the pawns are
are ready to roll check now one last
hope here on c3 gone and if black plays
Bishop b6 the last look c6 this was
played group d three rookie for d2 and
after rookie six there was 95 yeah IAM
the world champion resigned he is human
after all isn't this a good thing really
it's not like I'm glad that he's losing
games but it's just very reassuring that
even cars with is sometimes really
machine like quality so you just think
sometimes stop doing any mistakes what's
going on here he can really play em play
a big blunder from time to time and here
it happened this night x is seven is
quite remarkable that he that he didn't
see that um I didn't see them postgame
press conference it seemed that what I
gathered from from reporters that he
said he didn't really felt like that was
this was his day from the very beginning
sometimes sometimes this happens really
you have those kind of off days in chess
or in other areas where you need some
sort of
yeah well you need a high level of
concentration sometimes you just have
those days where nothing is really
happening to you it's it's also a matter
of physical shape I mean cousin usually
it's known for being in top shape is
very good athlete and and everything but
it sometimes happens you just eat
something that you don't really cannot
digest probably or whatever something
that it's not not going right and then
you have those kind of off days it just
happens it's certainly a good thing for
the tournament here as now kawana has
scott this important win Carlton only on
+1 now so it's a wide-open thing now
this tournament okay I hope you enjoyed
the coverage for this game um if I'm not
mistaken there is around tomorrow they
play up to round five and then only
after that they have a rest day so I'll
be back tomorrow with yet another rod
thanks for watching